كما يواصل عدوانه الغاشم على اهلنا في
ضفتنا ضفه العياش من خلال الاعدامات
الميدانيه وتدمير البنيه التحتيه واعتقال
الالاف من ابناء
شعبنا لقد ارتكب العدو خلال اليومين
الماضيين جرائم مروعه بحق اهلنا المدنيين
العزل في المناطق الوسطى من قطاع غزه في
مخيمات المغازي والبريج والنصيرات ومدينه
خان يونس الصامده في وجه اله الحرب
الصهيونيه النازيه امعانا وانتقاما من
فشله الذريع امام بساله وابداع رجال كتائب
الشهيد عز الدين
القسام لقد ارتقى حتى اليوم ما يزيد عن
21000 من الشهداء وجرح اكثر من
5000 معظمهم من النساء والاطفال بنسبه
تجاوزت
70% وهناك اكثر من 8000 بلاغ عن مفقودين
تحت الانقاض في انحاء متفرقه من قطاع
غزه علاوه على صور الوحشيه
والبربريه التي يبثها الاعلام مما يصل
اليه من جزء من المعاناه كالصور التي بثت
اليوم في تعريه الاطفال والشيوخ في هذا
الجو قارص البروده
والشماته بهم وهم يعانون اننا في هذا
المقام نترحم على ارواح شهداء شعبنا
الابرار ونسال الله تعالى ان يشافي الجرحى
والمصابين وان يمن بالحريه على
الاسرى والمعتقلين قريبا ونقف هنا بكل فخر
واعتزاز امام ملاحم الصمود والصبر والرباط
والتضحيه التي
يصنعها اهلنا في قطاع غزه دفاعا عن انفسهم
وعن كرامتهم وعن حقهم وعن وطنهم لا يع لا
يعبؤون بالام مهما كانت
التضحيات في تصاعد العدوان وصمود شعبنا
ومقاومته لم يترك النازيون الجدد نوعا من
الاسلحه والذخائر المحرمه دوليا الا
واستعملوه بساديه ووحشيه وانتقام موجه حين
ذلك ضد كل مقومات الحياه الانسانيه والبنى
التحتيه فاستهدف المدارس والمساجد
والكنائس والمستشفيات في قطاع غزه
واستخدموا مرارا قنابل مدمره وحارقه في
مناطق اعلن عنها انها امنه للمدنيين كما
استخدم جيش الاحتلال النازيه في هذه
المعركه قنابل لم يسبق لاي جيش في العالم
ان يستخدمها في المناطق المدنيه وفوق كل
ذلك يفاخر ساسته بانهم يشاركون في هذه
الجريمه علنا وهذه صوره لرئيس هذا الكيان
هرتزوغ وهو يوقع على القذائف التي تلقى
على رؤوس المدنيين والحمم التي تستهدف
الامنين يوقع توقيعا يقول نثق بكم يثق
بالجريمه ويثق بالنار التي يصبها على شعب
ويثق بقتل النساء والاطفال هذه ثقافتهم
هذه ثقافه داعميه هذه ثقافه هذا الكيان
وثقافه الاداره الامريكيه الداعمه له ان
هذه المجازر المروعه وحرب الاباده
الجماعيه التي يرتكبها هذا الجيش الاكثر
اجراما وناز في العالم مدعوما بالمال
والسلاح الامريكي فاقت في بشاعتها وهمجي
كل جرائم الحرب التي ارتكبت في العصر
الحديث من عمر البشريه ان ثلاثي
الاجرام يعيش في هذه الايام حاله احباط
وتخبط حيث لم يحقق هذا الثلاثي ولا حكومته
اي هدف من اهدافهم العدوانيه المعلنه ولن
يحققوا غير هزيمه مدويه باذن الله لقد
افشل بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى اولا ثم
صمود وصبر وتضحيات شعبنا وشجاعته وبقدم
وبساله ابطال كتائب القسام المضفره وكتائب
المقاومه الباسله كل خطط نتنياهو وحكومته
النازيه وجيشه المذعور والمهزوم فلا نزوح
ولا تهجير ولا انكسار ولا استسلام لشعبنا
ولا انتصار على المقاومه ولا استعاده
للاسرى دون الرضوخ شروط المقاومه اننا في
هذا السياق من قصص الصمود البطوليه نثمن
موقف المسيحيين من ابناء شعبنا الفلسطيني
في ارضنا المحتله وفي الشتات الرافضين
للاحتلال والعدوان واعلانهم الحداد وعدم
الاحتفال باعيادهم
تضامنا مع قطاع غزه كما نثمن المواقف
المواقف الرافضه للقاء رؤساء الداخل
الفلسطيني المحتل عام
48 برئيس الكيان الصهيوني الذي رايتم
صورته توا هذه المواقف المشرفه تؤكد مجددا
ان شعبنا بكل مكوناته موحد ضد مخططات
الاحتلال الذي يستهدف الارض والهويه
والمقدسات ويستهدف حريه واستقلال
شعبنا انما يجري يؤكد ان نتنياهو اركان
جيشه وحكومته النازيه انما يتحرك بلا هدف
ولا سقف ولا رؤيه وينتقل من فشل الى فشل
لا ينجح الا في شيء واحد قتل النساء
والاطفال واستهداف المدنيين وان التفكك
والخلاف وتباين الخطاب بين اركان الحرب
الصهاينه بات لا يخفى على احد وسببه ان
القسامه وفصائل المقاومه قد نسفت اهدافهم
اوهامهم حول غزه كما ينسف المجاهدون
دباباتهم ويصطادون جنودهم في كل ساعه على
امض على امتداد قطاع غزه المقاوم ان امام
نتنياهو الذي يكذب على شعبه وعلى العالم
خيار واحد لا سواه وهو الاعتراف بالفشل
ومواجهه مصيره بناء على ذلك ان من مشاهد
الفشل الصهيوني الطافيه على السطح ارتباك
لسان الكذب والزيف للناطق العسكري
الصهيوني امام اسئله الصحفيين التي يطلع
عليها مسبقا ومع ذلك يرتبك ولا يجيب وساو
ببساطه ان قيادته تمده بمعلومات غير صحيحه
وتخفي عنه الكثير من حقائق
الميدان ان الاحتلال يسعى لبناء صوره
انجاز واهيه فيعرض بعض انفاق المقاومه
معلنا عثوره على خمس جثث لاسرى كانوا لدى
المقاومه ولا يكشف امام جمهوره ان القسام
عرض تسجيلا لثلاثه منهم وهم احياء ثم كشف
ان جيش نتنياهو قتلهم وقد سبق ان عرضنا
ذلك في مؤتمر سابق واليوم نعرض مقطعا
لفيديو من مقابله لوزير الحرب الصهيوني
الحالي يف جلنت بثت على التلفزه
الاسرائيليه عام
2018 يتحدث فيه عن ضعف القوه العسكريه
لحركه حماس وعزز الحركه عن الاستمرار في
بناء الانفاق وبناء القوه العسكريه وفي
هذا المقطع بالذات يتوقع بانه وفي العام
2019 لن تكون هناك انفاق لغزه اترككم مع
هذه
[موسيقى]
اللقطات
ر
[موسيقى]
ز
2019 هذا كان عام 2018 هذه اللقطات
[موسيقى]
لقد انجزت المقاومه
اهدافها وحققت ما سعت اليه
واتمتع الاحتلال وها هو وزير حربهم يقف
مشدوها بعد خمس سنوات من تصريحاته تلك
ليرى عجائب فعل المقاومه
وانجازاتها تكثر هذه الايام تصريحات من
عدد من المسؤولين في الكيان الصهيوني حول
فشل جيشهم في تحقيق انتصار وفشل نتنياهو
في تحقيق اي من الاهداف التي تبجح بها
وكان اخرها تصريحات رئيس اركان جيش
الاحتلال السابق او الاسبق دان حلوتس الذي
قال فيها لقد خسرنا الحرب ضد حماس وان
انتصارنا سيكون بازاحه نتنياهو ان مثل هذه
التصريحات تعكس اقرارا بالفشل وانتصارا
للمقاومه وتؤكد ان المقاومه لن تنكسر بل
ان نتنياهو وجيشه هو الذي سيكسر وسيد حر
مهزوما باذن
الله فيما يتعلق بتبادل
الاسرى كثر في الاونه الاخيره الحديث عن
مبادرات ومقترحات حول التفاوض لتبادل
الاسرى واريد ان اوضح هنا نقاطا
محدده اننا نؤكد موقف الحركه الواضح
بضروره واولو وقف العدوان الاجرامي النزي
على
شعبنا ونؤكد هنا ايضا ان الحركه تلقت
مبادرات ومقترحات من عدد من الدول تتعلق
بهذه المعركه والحركه كانت دوما منفتحه
على كل المبادرات التي تحقق وقفا شاملا
للعدوان على شعبنا وعلى كل ما يحقق مصالح
شعبنا
العليا فشعبنا لا ينتظر هدنا
مؤقته يخرقها الاحتلال بمزيد من المجازر
وجرائم الحرب الوحشيه ضد المدنيين
الابرياء وانما ينتظر بعد كل هذه التضحيات
وقفا شاملا للعدوان وبكل
اشكاله اما فيما يتعلق بالشراكه الامريكيه
في هذا
العدوان ان اصرار الاداره الامريكيه على
استمرار الحرب ضد شعبنا الفلسطيني في غزه
ومنع الدعوات الى وقفها ثم تصريحات
بايدن المطالبه لنتنياهو بوقف الحرب في
صوره سمجه انما هي تاكيد ان هذه الاداره
هي من تقود هذا العدوان وانها هي المسؤوله
عن دماء الاطفال والنساء التي تسفك
بالاسلحه والقنابل الامريكيه وان يدي
بايدن ملطخه بل غارقه بدماء اطفال
غزه انها بهذه
التصريحات تمارس اداره بايدون بايدن افحش
ل لغه للنفاق فهي تتحدث عن المدنيين
وحمايتهم من جهه ثم تتحدث عن حمايه
النازيين والقتله ومدهم بالسلاح والحمايه
السياسيه من جهه اخرى ان هذه المواقف تجعل
من بايدن وادارته شريكا في الجريمه وتحمله
المسؤوليه السياسيه والاخلاقيه
والانسانيه والقانونيه التي لن تسقط
بالتقادم
وان التصعيد الامريكي في البحر الاحمر
انما هو محاوله مكشوفه لتوفير الحمايه
للاحتلال حتى يواصل حرب الاباده التي
يجيدها ضد المدنيين العزل وهنا نؤكد لا
يحتاج الامر الى ذكاء ولا حصافه ولا حكمه
سياسيه ليستنتج وبوضوح ان هذا التصعيد
الامريكي انما هو وصفه كامله لاتساع دائره
النار فيما يتعلق بالحراك العالمي
والمواقف
الدوليه اولا نشيد بموقف الاخوه انص الله
في اليمن موقفهم المبدئي والاخلاقي في
نصره اشقائهم في قطاع غزه ضد الحرب
والحصار والتجويع وجريمه الاباده الكامله
التي تمارس ضد شعبنا بالصوت والصوره بثا
حئا على الهواء مباشره واستعدادهم
للمواجهه في سبيل
ذلك ثانيا نثمن استمرار الحراك الجماهيري
العالمي في كل المدن والعواصم العالميه
تضا نا مع غزه والذي يتزايد ويحرج الدول
الداعمه لهذا العدوان ويضغط باتجاه تغيير
مواقفها اننا ندعو هذه الجماهير الحره وكل
اصحاب الضمائر الحيه في العالم الى مواصله
كل مظاهر التضامن والتاييد لشعبنا وقضيتنا
العادله وتصعيد كل الاشكال والمظاهرات حتى
يتوقف العدوان ولتكن الايام القليله
المتبقيه من هذا العام صرخه عالميه موحده
بكل اللغات وعبر جميع الاديان والمذاهب
والاعراق تنادي بقوه وبصوت الانسانيه
الواحد اوقف الحرب على غزه اوقفوا الجريمه
النازيه التي يرتكبها الكيان الصهيوني في
غزه ثالثا نرحب بمواقف بعض الدول
الاوروبيه الرافضه لجرائم الاحتلال
الصهيوني
وندعوها للعمل من اجل اتخاذ قرار موحد في
الاتحاد الاوروبي بوقف هذا العدوان وعدم
الرضوخ للضغوط والاملاء الامريكيه
والانتصار للقيم التي يعلنون قيم الحريه
والعداله
والاستقلال رابعا نحذر كل الدول والحكومات
من التعاطي والتساوى مع المخططات التي
يروجها المجرم نتنياهو وعصابته الاجراميه
فيما اسماه الهجره الطوعيه لسكان غزه
ونؤكد ان شعبنا بصموده
وبمقابل هذه المخططات من قبل وسيفشل كل
المخططات التي تستهدف وجوده على ارضه او
النيل من حقوقه المشروعه خامسا ندين عمليه
الاغتيال الجبانه التي استهدفت العميده في
الحرس الثوري الشهيد السيد رضي الموسوي
الذي ارتقى على طريق تحرير القدس عاملا
لدعم المقاومه واسنادها وذلك في اعتداء
جبان وانتهاك صارخ لسياده دوله عربيه كما
وندين العدوان الامريكي الذي استهدف مقرات
الحشد الشعبي في العراق في محاوله لمنع
المقاومه العراقيه من القيام بواجهه
بواجبها تجاه غزه العزه وفي انتهاك صارخ
كذلك لسيا دوله عربيه اختم بالترحم على
الشهداء الشهداء جميعا شهداء شعبنا
ومقاومتنا شهداء على طريق القدس وبالدعاء
بالشفاء للجرحى والمصابين والحريه للاسرى
والمعتقلين وبالنصر العظيم لشعبنا
ومقاومتنا المضفره وانه لجهاد نصر او
استشهاد والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته